pour cette vidéo j'ai décidé de mettre
en mode ricains ce que je trouve un
gangster tee shirt large casquette et
tout a dit ouais alors oui beaucoup
d'entre vous le savent déjà j'ai des
contacts et ainsi que d'autres youtuber
pour participer à l'émission
pouf et enfin mais vraiment une équipe
de choc
[Musique]
mais on n'était pas habillé 1 on est en
maniant dans l'émission
je trouve que la particularité de cette
scène c'est que si tu changes la musique
ça change tout le truc j'ai des bons
bref que vous l'aurez deviné avec le nom
ces bandits de flash la nouvelle
émission sur tf1 qui détient d'ailleurs
le record mondial du temps d'attentes à
revoir vos ongles mg je passe tu te
rends compte que c'est devant cette
émission que tu attends le plus de temps
de toute ta vie pour voir un plongeon
quand il était petit yoann avait très
très peur ce qu'un jour et plongea dans
du pipi depuis super se réveillant le
châssis achats mais bon c'est ça un
rapport dans un instant durant sept
heures contre outaouais c-32 candidats
on va bien être évidemment évalués par
un jury très bon ben on en est très très
sévère ça se voit n'avait rien d'autre à
[ __ ] que le tout présenté par un mec
plutôt chelou qui se met notamment nous
doit l'emmener équipe arsenault donc
forcément pas grand chose quand je crois
que ce mec a un très très gros souci est
bien pour lui dire qu'on l'entend pas je
répète lui dire qu'on ne l'entend pas à
et en consulat ou alors peut-être qu'il
venait juste de voir la scène un peu gay
et du coup chez ba au moins ici on
n'assiste pas à ce genre de scène et je
vous emmerde
juste une petite anecdote concernant le
générique qui fait générer des années 80
est sûr qu'en 2013 ça passe dit plutôt
bizarre quand même quand ils sont
atterrés
change de chaîne au médecin en charge de
chef but au maire bref look c'est la
parodie de splash version youtuber y
aura des épisodes chaque semaine sur la
chaîne de soleil rouge chez la vache ça
se passe passez voir un jour et moi je
vous balance un extrait laisse d'or bref
je vais voir assuré et j'espère que la
puissance du métro sera avec moi plus
[Musique]